oh this visi Altaf legend I'm trying to
get the way to say let's have our last
talk before the reception but of course
Zico is going to standards on
architecture yeah new way of looking at
depth of networks alright so thanks
thanks for for inviting me here I'm at
ease and and actually I changed the
topic of this talk a little bit from
within the schedule I did not get the
change in topic in on time but it's it's
actually quite related to what I what I
was talking about before but in
preparing the talk we actually have some
new work in this in this area and so I
want to kind of focus on the particular
new way of viewing depth in in in deep
networks and so this this this model
we've been working on this is largely
work with my students as you buy as well
as vladlen colton from intel the model
we were working on is called deep
equilibrium models and because it's a
common trope in the machine learning
these days to have this kind of title
the subtext here is one implicit layer
is all you need but of course because
that is all you need is also very
overused I'll have to start clarify them
and say no really we actually have a
proof in everything this is actually all
you need which seems weird right we
don't we don't think about one layer
being sufficient to do much and deep
learning hence the name deep learning so
I want to talk about it's not actually
maybe that deep a statement no pun
intended but I want to talk about what I
mean by that and and what this model is
actually really doing and how I think we
should be thinking about depth
differently when it comes to deep
learning so ok let's start with the
story we all tell this maybe it's not
for me start the story we all tell about
depth which is that when you have a deep
network you hit your inputs the first
layer is process you know a low-level
features and then as you move through
this network you get more and more
abstract representations of the network
these are a mistake yours I just I think
google searched deep neural network and
you find some like this I do
site where I got this picture from I did
that intentionally because actually
everyone steals these pictures they
steal them from my officemate in in grad
school so I remember when Hong Lockley
was was building these pictures I was
next thing next to him in my office in
grass go they'd become now famous these
notions of you know the first thing is
finding edges the next one is finding
off parts of objects and last one is
finding whole faces and things like this
so this is obviously a true
understanding of depth right this does I
mean things like this approximately do
we do observe them and deep networks but
I want to at least think about a
slightly different way of thinking about
depth and the fact that it will work
these models I'll talk about will work
as well at least on some tasks as these
sort of more traditional hierarchical
weights thing about things I think says
something kind of important about how we
build and think about deep networks so
what does what does this talk about this
talk is about how we can go how I'm
gonna show you how we can take a deep
network almost any deep network not
quite all of them but almost any deep
network and replace it with an
equivalent version that is one layer
deep it'll have the same number of
parameters we're not doing exponential
blow-up another fail to have same number
of parameters and they'll have the same
representational capacity exactly
actually but it'll be one layer deep now
that there's obviously a trick here the
trick is we have to move from our notion
of layers as being just feed-forward
computation to what we call implicit
layers their layers defined at the
solution to some nonlinear equation and
we do this in sort of a very easy way to
move to get this result but the actual
interesting thing is when you take this
idea and then throw away depth and just
think about deep networks is trying to
solve nonlinear equations at least in
some domains I'm going to look at
sequence modeling particular they work
basically just as well so you can get
just as good empirical performance even
on some large scale language modeling
tasks as you do with these very complex
deeper networks so that's the agenda and
here's how I'm gonna do it I'm first
going to talk about generally implicit
layers in deep learning well what I mean
by this and more important sort of how
these were
what else we've used them for and how
you treat them as layers in the deep
network they I'm going to talk about our
particular instantiation of this called
a deep equilibrium model and this is
sort of this this this specialization of
this notion that gets at this notion of
you know replacing deep networks with
something a little different even though
we call it a deep model still because
shallow equilibria network doesn't sound
quite as good
I mean I'll finally talk about some
results and in fact this is probably
most important part in a lot of senses
I'll talk about results showing that
when you use these things so sort of
throw away our traditional notion of
depth and just use these what we call
these equilibrium models we actually end
up getting very good performance on on
some language Mally tasks while also
having things like better better memory
consumption things like this we don't
have to maintain hold depth anymore yes
I got a question call it the whole thing
one layer right yeah so there's one
non-linearity somebody it's gonna be one
sort of non-linearity applied afterafter
within your units but with this implicit
function form so I'll get to that in a
second
yeah it's not gonna be that cheating
because it's still cheating but it's not
just like saying oh we'll call a whole
network just one layer now it's not
quite that that shipment that much
cheating
okay so let me talk about implicit
layers first I'm associate something
that comes up in a lot of contacts it
comes up actually mainly in the context
which which will sort of the original
topic from my talk which was embedding
constraints into deep networks and we've
used this sort of formulation in a lot
of different ways within different
aspects of deep learning so the idea
though is very simple the idea is now
we're back to the normal deep setting so
you say we have you know some input X a
bunch of hidden layers and some output Y
a normal deep layer or a normal layer in
this network so what would like to be
called an explicit layer it means we
haven't supposed a form of how you
compute the next output given the inputs
that layer all I'm sort of arguing for
here or all I will sort of advocate for
is replacing these in this notion with
an implicit layer and it says instead of
representing a layer as a computation
about how you actually you know compute
the output just represent a layer kind
of as a route-finding procedure so we
have some nonlinear function
and we want to form our output such that
F of our input layer and the output
equals zero where this is some nonlinear
function here it turns out this
representation is very very powerful
what you can do with this as you might
imagine because we all work with you
know finding and in solving equation
like this is obviously a very powerful
paradigm if you can do it when you can
do it this type of layer has both a lot
of applications and it sort of opens up
I think a new possibilities new ways of
looking at what we mean by a layer in a
deep network so let me give a few
examples actually a past work we've used
that uses this kind of layer to I think
you know nice effect
in deep networks yeah yeah yeah all this
some prior work first this actually was
was the main topic we were sort of thing
with before but I decide to switch a
little bit let's let's spend a little
time talking about what what good is
this all right what does actually buy
you to think about implicit layers the
first one I'm gonna I bring up is some
work we did a couple years ago with my
student Brenda yeah another question
writing it in this implicit way is the
way the control theory community
developed back in the seventies yeah
absolutely so I'm so so all this goes
back decades if not centuries about how
you actually back Papa these things and
there's it's really classical stuff it's
nothing new mathematically here it's
more of a different way of sort of
thinking if I don't but yeah I'll get to
that in a second
okay so the first one of the first
applications we have this was an auction
we called the op net layer so op net was
basically a layer in a network where the
layer itself solves a quadratic program
what I mean by that is the output of
this layer is the Arg min over sum over
some variable Z of a QP where the QP
itself is set up parameterize by the
previous layer that can be very
arbitrary right so the you know the R
cubed is a cost term here and our
quadratic and linear cost terms can
depend actually arbitrarily on the
parameters the inputs the layers the I
the constraints the linear the
equalities and inequalities can also
depend arbitrarily on the parameters Zi
the inlets the network and you can have
of course you know parameters layer to
you like some of these can be fixed some
them can because parameters the network
but this is the this is essentially a
layer in a network now if we think about
the layers output as being the solution
not I mean again not the value but the
actual argument the solution to this
optimization problem and that paper we
showed that actually you can do a lot of
stuff with this you can represent lot of
functions more efficiently more
compactly than you can with most
networks and you can also solve some
sort of cool problems that deal with
things like like denoising images or or
solving a little puzzle games and stuff
like this and now the important point
from this president of this implicit
functions though is how we go about
representing this layer because it seems
hard I mean how do you differentiate
through an argument it's actually not
hard but it but but it seems hard upon
first glance and the way you do it is
you represent exactly this network as an
implicit layer or that's re this layer
as an apposite layer so the way we know
we find a solution organization problem
is through the KKT conditions right
those specify for a convex problem at
least as long as you make this convex
here they specify sort of conditions
that will guarantee optimality of this
program so you think of the solution
really the solution both of the next
output
Slayer as well as the dual variables
those could also be outputs if you
wanted them to be you have to find you
know a Zi plus one a lambda and a new
such that they satisfy these equations
use the optimality conditions the
details here are important is the
standard equations they actually also
have to satisfy feasibility here but
these are the ones that matter for
differentiation you have to find ones
that satisfy these equations these are
not linear equations they're nonlinear
because of this this complementarity
condition here so they're not easy to
solve but they they are solvable it's
been of course ton of work on doing this
and the key point here though is that
this layer the seemingly complex layer
is easily parameterised in terms of this
implicit function solving this implicit
equation alright now I want to give a
few more examples just one more example
just actually I'm not going to have any
of the math here because it's the it's a
little bit more complex but it's the
exact same idea we had a paper this year
earlier at ICML on doing a similar thing
for solving I guess a smooth
approximation to Sat problems within a
network so you can also formulate an
optimization variant of sat called the
max at problem and you can form a semi
definite relaxation of that problem
there's a lot of steps here actually cuz
these answers looking a form of a fast
solver if that's some different problem
but basically a very similar set of
techniques hold and you can characterize
solutions to this problem the sort of
satisfiability problem as those
solutions that satisfy a particular in
this case just sort of equality
conditions non linear equalities but
just some sense of equality conditions
and this basically gives us our implicit
form of this layer now that's I'm not
gonna get into details here we can do
some very cool things with this felt
like we can learn to solve Sudoku
problems just from data so given a bunch
of Sudoku problems that you're not even
that many because it sort of constrains
the system to learn logical
representations we're able to do things
like give it inputs and output to this
form and it eventually will learn the
rules of Sudoku and can play Sudoku on
new problems even though it's never you
know being told the rules of Sudoku come
in in any formal way so again not not
getting too much of this because I've
done a lot of work in this with this
area we've also worked in things like
physics differentiable physics
simulations
we've worked at game game solving so
finding Nash equilibrium
all these things can be represented in
this font and in this form of implicit
layers so just finding some you know
next output of the layer that satisfies
some some nonlinear function and the
question of course that comes up which
is pretty easy to answer is how do we
incorporate layers like this into you
know a traditional deep Network well
this really involves is how do we
compute the relative jacobians like
erecting any more facility highly
backprop through one of these implicit
layers unfortunately this is again what
this was this is a really old technique
it just goes by the name of
differentiation it's at least decades if
not centuries olds that keeps old in
this instantiation centuries but you
apply something called implicit function
theorem and the idea is if you have we
know that our solution we have this
equation holding right we have f of Z I
our previous layer and our next layer
I'm going to write this as a function of
Z I because of course our solution is
actually a function of the input layer
we know this holds and this this this
this function is zero at the at the
optimum and now we just differentiate
this thing so we differentiate with
respect to say our input that would be
the same thing differentiate the
parameters of this thing we apply the
chain rule so the first term we take
this first term here we get this
Jacobian we take the second term here
both these two terms the the Z eyes are
treated as constants was just the
jacobians at the actual solution and
then this term here this last one also
is just to clarify those two things or
things you know those are just standard
I'm at differentiation terms this last
one is the unknowns what we want what we
want to compute and so you just now have
a linear system that specifies your
solution this is just again it was a
differentiation that goes back decades
if not centuries actually yeah
sorry what's that right so that there
are a lot of questions like that I'm
going to assume here that they are
unique for the most part if they're not
unique in this Rakow be and will not be
invertible there are things you can do
to make it invertible when it's not
quite invertible like a little bit of
regularization right so just you have
you know minimize a little hinge to a
little a little hinge here my other side
a little l2 term on it in addition to
make it unique that's usually not that
big a deal
the bigger question actually is how you
solve this thing because they typically
are pretty I mean we're solving an
inverse now to do back prop instead of
just you know computing a matrix
transpose and and that can be hard but
the nice thing about this is that it's
actually typically easier to do this
just you know solving linear systems and
so it's usually easier than finding the
root to begin with so if you can find a
way to solve this implicit layer to
begin with it usually pretty much gives
you an indirect method to solve this
thing as well and then we'll end up
exploiting that we actually put that in
all the previous works we have you use
your solved lucien technique here to
essentially give you an equivalent one
to solve the back prop equation as well
and there's actually a very general form
of that where you can you can derive
that formally to a solution technique
here we'll give you an iterative method
to solve the reverse but we typically do
it by hand still we're not sort of doing
it quite in the fully on my
differentiation mode yet
okay so there's one important takeaway
that I want to make after all of this
though and that is and this is what we
exploit in all these past works is that
to differentiate three deposit layer we
are not advocating unrolling the
solution procedure and then you know
Trina has a computation graph and back
propping through that that's expensive
especially memory expensive right
because they could take a lot of time
and a lot of computations to find that
root of that equation we're not
advocating for that what we are instead
advocating for is finding that solution
using a technique you want and then
analytically differentiating through it
with the people is that function through
which typically is much much more memory
efficient and better in a lot of ways
yes question I just wanted to give more
examples on these so for example going
using sparse coding yeah yeah and that
they simply see the differentiation
that's also yeah yeah so I think Gillian
Merrill had some work on that or the
butt-ends also been going on much
further than that I think that's you
know how to differentiate through
optimization problems how to
differentiate through these these are
puzzle functions yeah it's it's a great
technique not actually used all that
much still but but no one for a very
long time yeah so was a mess less nips
one of the winning papers and what we
knew papers was about differential in
that paper yes so actually they actually
it's very late not very related but it's
it's definitely really it's actually
what I'm more what I'm talking about
next but that that actually is implicit
layer so you can think of an OD e as a
solution a set of trajectory that
satisfy some equation and the adjoint is
exactly the the backward pass operator
and at joins you know have been used for
decades and OD ease so they're very
they're very well understood yeah that's
also an implicit layer though would be
would be the way I would characterize it
yeah
this duration yeah so I would not I
would not advocate for unrolling
iteration scheme something especially a
bad thing to do because you have to
maintain your intermediate products or
that whole unrolled scheme that kind of
feeds a lot of the purpose of this nice
this autist nice stuff and in fact one
of the big benefits were gonna highlight
from this is the memory efficiency is
that you don't have to worry about back
propping through multiple layers
maintaining multiple things so that's
sort of the benefit here in some sense
but but that's that's a they both do
have some advantages to I think it's
just better to differentiate
analytically 3:6 when you can do it okay
so having said that let me now propose a
particular class of apposite layers that
I think raises questions about what we
mean by depth and networks and
interesting ways so so I think we
haven't quite figured out all the
implications of this yet but I I think
it's a cool idea and I'm excited to
think what people cited see what people
think about it okay so here's our agenda
so what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
show how we can represent pretty much
not quite any but almost any deep
network with a single hidden layer
Network with the catch being that this
hidden layer needs to be an implicit
layer it's actually a very trivial
reduction here it's not hard at all you
could maybe even imagine how it's gonna
work but it's still saying something
interesting about it because once we do
it we're gonna say let's forgo because
we can do this now let's forego any sort
of notion about you know depth as being
some hierarchy of different things let's
talk about depth as just computing the
equilibrium point of some function of
some dynamical system that's what we're
gonna think of as depth and those
equilibrium points end up being really
good feature representations for our
input even though it's just one layer
kind of repeatedly applied or even a
root found for one layer it's again
similar but distinct from this neural od
idea what it stores more about a
trajectory and then differentiating
through this continuous time thing is
much more discrete discrete thing but
but definitely related was that
the reduction in general will not have
sinned number of notes no but the big
empirical result that I will show which
is next section is that if you keep the
number another quit the number of notes
number parameters constant from this
network to this network it works
basically just as well it leaves on the
pass that we do at news and we're doing
some real large-scale tasks here some
language modeling tasks that are pretty
large scale and this works
plenty well okay so let me go through
what I what I mean by this okay so so
again traditional layers here so so
first of all we're gonna consider a
specific class of network to do this
production and it's gonna be called
that's what we call a weight tied input
injected network and we actually need
both those things or doesn't quite work
so what do I mean by that well normal
networks you know you have your input
you apply a bunch of different layers to
get your output well we're gonna do ring
cuz it's guys consider the following
Network a network where you have your
input and at every layer is after the
first one you apply the same matrix W so
it's always the same matrix you're
applying this is what's gonna cause it
to be an equilibrium point really
and you always also entry inject your
input into that layer so you know the
instead of just like like a relative
linear function here you have say a rel
you of some fixed matrix applied to your
input plus some linear term applied to
your served by the previous layer plus
some linear term applied to your input
plus as a bias term so we're gonna
consider these types of networks now the
first thing you might say is that this
seems like a pretty big restriction on
the class of networks but it actually
isn't at least not not fundamentally
because it's easy to reduce any network
like this to a weight tight network and
the idea there is you just can do it by
just expanding your depth to capture
both layers so say I have some network
like there's some iteration like this or
you know I have Z to equals some
function of Z 1 Z 3 equals some function
of Z of Z 2 I can capture all of this by
just embedding it in a single in a
single network where I sort of have you
know a concatenation of all my hidden
vectors there I apply the same matrix
each time and I get the output there
this is equivalent to these two it's
cheating to be clear it's totally
totally an easy reduction it's not hard
at all also key is it this is not a this
does not become a single layer network
right you have to apply this thing twice
to actually make it equivalent to
but if you apply this same you know wait
tide network you get the same thing now
we are not going to do this in practice
we're not going to this is quite as a
very specific sparsity pattern for this
matrix here we're not going to do that
what we're gonna do is we're gonna said
just match parameter accounts between
you know shrink this down its match
parameter comes between this and the
original thing it will work just as well
so we will ignore any this sort of you
know structured version the structured
version of the equivalence but just I'm
gonna sort of making the argument here
other things are in fact equivalent so
we can produce any normal feed-forward
network to a weight tied Network yeah
yeah well learn U and W will both be
parameters here I'm omitting you here
but yes you and W are both going to be
parameters they're just the parameters
of this network yeah okay so
theoretically know is not a big
restriction because they're equivalent
and empirically no to it turns out you
take basically any network and you
repeatedly apply just a bigger weight
tied version of that network and they
work about the same now if you just do
this sort of naively and just apply the
bigger weight type network repeatedly
it's kind of slower so you actually
don't really gain very much and you're
still sort of memory intensive because
it's a back property the whole thing so
it's not a great thing to do naively but
it's still a reasonable strategy
actually the paper on this that talked
about sort of an equivalence between RN
ends and convolutional networks based
upon this idea of unrolling weight tied
networks so unrolling weight tied in
depth where every layer of depth at the
same weights applied to it and this is
one work we had at that occurred this
year zero maybe zero I mean they don't
matter right like this up here this
first one so it doesn't matter make
these zero when you when you start oh
the question was it looks like you're
feeding in Z 2 and Z 3 and I would say
no so see these are zero initially so
initial vector you feed in is z100 after
the next time it'll be 0 z to 0 and the
next time it'll be 0 0 z 3 you can also
keep them around to do one you can make
the final thing z1 z2 these three by
just play you know propagating terms
forward but it's it
it's easy to keep it's easy yes yeah yes
we're gonna like prawns in a second I'll
get to that way when we talk about / for
the actual performance of these things
yeah
yeah so the first line would if you
initialize your vector state with z1
equals to Z 1 I mean this is sort of
just hopefully you can see how this
works right you make Z 1 equal to is
whatever input you want in that
left-hand side you make it a 2 term 0
you apply it once and you will get Z 2
out and the thing you'll play it again
you will get 0 0 Z 3 and your
interventive there so you can I mean and
you can do whatever you want if you
could maintain Z 1 if you want to also
is adding like a residual term but that
doesn't really matter the point is is
the trivial reduction if you want to do
it this way and on the only point I'm
making is that is that we don't actually
lose that much by this weight tying
structure ok so now hopefully that is
becoming kind of obvious here the idea
is we're talking about deep networks
that means the roads are deep in quotes
here as this repeated applications of
the same function where this is a
function of both the previous layer and
the input and that's our deep network so
in practice and we'll discuss this is a
bit more shortly whenever you do this
with a with an actual deep network and
apply them repeatedly this process will
converge to some equilibrium point and
so we can think of in some sense the
infinite depth neural network as just
computing an equilibrium point of this
dynamical system that's what it's doing
in depth now there's a lot of
assumptions there you know is it stable
this is going to converge etc I'll talk
about those more in a second we don't
have too many strong results there but
it's actually in practice the answer is
yes they always converge because if they
didn't converge it'd be a really bad
deep network to begin with because a
hundred layers deep if it's not stable
it's already gonna blow up
so we've already designed stable deep
networks in this sense now our model the
DB equilibrium model all we're gonna do
is we're gonna advocate to find this
point directly which of course is to be
on finding the root of this minus Z star
X for finding composite layer still all
we're advocating for is that instead of
trying to find this in a naive way by
just repeated application of our of our
function just do this a root find
technique to find that directly
whatever you want for route-finding use
one these gonna be faster than repeated
application typically let's just find it
with root mat finding methods we use
Bruins method you can use a lot of them
and then endlessly differentiate using
this implicit function theorem and
that's and that's that that that's it
for the deep equilibrium model okay so
just to summarize here summary define so
now our task is nicer as deep learning
architects because we only have to find
a single layer we have to worry about
multiple layers you know and all the
connections I mean I know especially
like vision pass is gonna be harder
because it's halves we haven't worked in
those much we're talking about sequence
modeling it's a little easier here so we
need to find a single layer basically
and you know this is a simple version
you get a little bit more complex with
make transformers and things like that
so this is sort of a you know an
approximation what we have and the
forward pass users compute the
equilibrium point which I'm writing here
is just emphasize the implicit nature of
this written here is a route to some
nonlinear equation and then the backward
pass now is just we want to find
derivatives with respect to any print
parameter here we just imply that
implicit function theorem and what we
get out is the following thing you can
compute any gradient we want with its
loss by looking at the grams of loss
with respect to or our output of this
layer times this which is the coat
Jacobian of that term times whatever
grit whatever you know derivatives we
want there and that's just the
application of that rule
all right so that's it yeah regarding
these models so if I take if to be
something reasonable like a single
rather Leah can you specify some
interesting class of predictors that
these models can actually represent yeah
so so I mean right so I think yes if you
think of it Sorel you then buy that
collection before you can in theory
represent any deeper lu network because
you could always have this weird chain
structure in your in your W matrix it
sort of propagates things forward and
then ends after a certain amount of time
you can always sort of replicate if you
wanted to buy it by you know quad but by
a quadratic blow-up in parameter account
you could represent actually not really
because you have a lot of zeros but if
you didn't it's constraint it that way
you could always replicate an existing
deep architecture now I think yes so so
you
I mean bright you could always sort of
say that you know after a certain time
you don't use that last element in the
next person the next element so you even
though it's infinite depth it actually
converges after K iterations and you
have exactly the previous deep network
now we don't have to be clear we don't
do any of that in practice what we just
do is have a normal you know arbitrary
matrices for W and you and they converge
something kind of cool to be honestly
having at least tell you like what's the
what's the real class of functions is
representing here beyond that too much
so I think I think it'd be really
interesting to think about there more
from a more fundamental what's the real
representation of this thing and the
answer sort answer is you know we
haven't done much more than just say we
can represent other things kind of
easily
so meditation yes right so the question
was about you know we can't use our
differentiation right because you have
to yes in solve this equation exactly I
need to solve this with you know some
Broyden method too so yes you have to
implement a wrapper that sort of says
okay for whatever Jacobian your inner
layer has here's how we're gonna
implement the solver to keep ERG Cobian
so you know in patch we have a we have a
meta model where you plug in your layer
here and it will compute through through
its other differentiation to compute
what it what it knows about it will
compute this thing using broadens method
for the forward and backward passes okay
let's do that once right and then and
then you're good after that all right so
a few freely asked questions um the
first thing people always say is okay
you great you have a new more powerful
representation for deep learning people
why don't we just stack those together
and get even more power and the answer
which is I think is very cool here is
that it doesn't matter in this
formulation there's no advantage
representationally to stacking
equilibrium models together because you
have sort of two things like this so
they're both sort of equilibrium
computations here right this is the
first time the equilibrium point of this
first function f 1 then the clipping
point in the second punch and F 2 again
really trivial statement here this thing
is just the same as the equilibrium
point of one function you just tack two
functions together this is now a
function of both these variables and the
input X so it's just an equilibrium
point of a single bigger function this
is what's really nice about these equids
disorder inputs at layers is when you
have implicit layers there's no
representational advantage or or yeah
you don't add representational power
fundamentally by stacking them one layer
this is what I had in the beginning
right one layer is really all you need
you don't need more now for optimization
reasons or something like that maybe you
do want them maybe you want to separate
some sort of notion of modules but you
don't need them you can do without them
number two had to become the port I
think I got ready mentioned this we use
parens method the cool thing though is
this is which is sort of our first it's
you know a quasi Newton method it seems
reasonable all the time that this takes
I mean all the runtime that we were that
were adding here in some sense is all
just about finding a brute
a single equation now so if you know the
structure of your problem in a way to
let's to exploit that to find a root
more quickly you can actually solve
these things potentially much faster
that we haven't exploited that too much
yet and we use it for both the forward
and backward pass and I think there's
lots of hyper parameter optimization to
be done here to make these things much
faster yeah just think of F right now as
being this but what we're gonna do is
we're gonna make F like an LST M cell
we're gonna make F like a transport
myself as a transformer block it's what
we actually do because you can't compete
with the state-of-the-art with just a
rail you so what we have to do is we
make F essentially a single block of
like a transformer and that's actually
how we're gonna get results that are
that are competitive with the state of
the earth oh yeah it could be anything
any mean any any operator you can code
in Python it can be your f including
like you know a few stacks of layers if
you want to have like a transform with
self attention and a linear layer and
then a layer norm you could do all that
yeah so it's not quite one layer I guess
there but I'm cheating like Zack has
maybe called me out for a little bit
it's so kind of one layer yeah you can
stack a few so like like I mean like
what a transformer is right a
transformer is like the self attention
layer followed by a single feed-forward
layer followed by layer norm and there's
some other layer norms may be an
intermediate Li to you can do all that
and so we so that becomes our F for
example for the real state-of-the-art
models because you can't just do that
much without with a with a single value
you can't get there but it's only one
you know a transformer layer then after
you're done with that after you get your
single block your single cell your
you're good to go it just kind of
actually the mo people think about if I
think about the only architecture just
like the cell level so you have like a
cell but then you repeat that in this
infinitely unrolled weight tied sense
okay do they exist is equilibrium points
good question
zero theory about it because they may
not they're nonlinear functions are
eternally functions they're weird funds
that have been studied I mean we don't
know if self attention followed by layer
norm is really a contraction in all
cases or not but in practice yes of
course they converge because they didn't
converge there's no way us 18 layer
transformer we converge ever it would
already blow up after 18 layers so the
reality is these things do exist and in
practice we can find them
a lot more to be analyzed there and sort
of seen there but this is where we have
so far um what's the trade-off between
this this is really faster I mean you
would think maybe ideally okay that
maybe this is faster than deep network
right because we can we're just finding
one layer the answer is that right now
it's not faster it's about two to three
times slower at training and about two
to two times slower at inference time
the reason for that is that finding a
route is still a you know reasonably
intensive task and there in you know
even with a method like a quasi Newton
method it requires a few function
iterations and so typically requires you
know to find an actual route which is
more than what currently networks are
doing right they're just doing you know
18 layers or something like that to find
a real route you have to iterate these
things for a few times and so it takes a
little bit slower to train now it's much
much more memory efficient though
because you only have to maintain the
memory of one block because you're not
unrolling computation you're just doing
analytic differentiation so you can just
have that one block so it's more memory
efficient less a little bit slower but I
think it's actually can be brought down
a lot and we're actually in more than
like that one point five to two now if
we just sort of cut down the number of
broaden iterations and it still works
fine but so get convergence oh maybe not
exactly but it's good enough and it
still works just fine so there are
trade-offs involved but conceptually
it's it's simple right it's just saying
find one route then go from there okay
so now let me I should say them the main
thing which is it was just short but
actually isn't something the actual
punchline the best yes question
Yeah right so what I'm a third point is
this and sorry if I didn't actually say
that more formally before what I mean
the equilibrium point is you have a
point where you have a value for hidden
layer such that when I apply my function
to that to that value and the input I
get the same value out now because I'm
applying the same function layer after
layer in depth if I have this point but
that is equivalent to kind of the
infinite depth version of this network
so the point where the value does not
change anymore and hence it has
converged to its equilibrium
oh absolutely yeah yeah I mean you have
to solve this equation to find that
point it is a function of X I mean right
so if you ignore input injection this is
actually a good question like what did
you leave out input ingestion why do we
need that well if you do that then this
function has depend on the input anymore
which seems a pretty bad idea for a deep
model so you actually need your input
injection to actually have some
dependence on your input which which no
it's a good idea if our networks depend
on the input we yeah so if I give you a
big network with time waits yep how do I
find the function of increased function
FZ and wait wait with tide waits because
if you have tide weights and then this
is just already in that form a weight
tight network is already in the form of
a function I mean this is how function
this is how networks represented right
is the output a layer is is the the
output of a layer is you know some
function applied to the input of that
layer and in our case and the the X so
you already have this is the function f
here
yes I should be
yes Oh F again yeah it should not only
be the shell only exists in equilibrium
it should be a stable equilibrium
meaning the points will converge that
equilibrium and again no reason why that
should happen in theory but it but of
all we can't prove it happens but in
reality the networks are really bad it
doesn't happen already and so they they
duper happen in practice there it's
contractive and it converges to a two I
mean again is it unique no reason why it
should be it's nonlinear in practice it
seems to be we haven't been able to find
cases where it doesn't seem to be unique
yeah you find like break expected is the
same is the same one yes yes yes yeah
yeah counter-examples functions that are
not that do not have equilibria many of
the worst case instructions are not
equilibria so digit extraction and all
the decorations they are not we do not
have equilibrium points yeah so there's
plenty of functions there that are not
contractive in this regard right it's a
nonlinear function of course it can be
knock attractive again real networks
typically are yeah great great question
okay so so excellent question so
question why is it anybody be contracted
I mean we're finding roots that's good
enough we can make it contract this
orderly with a Broyden iteration so yes
you don't actually need it but in
practice you just look you have it
anyway and so it's good enough now what
actually is interesting is that this is
maybe we'll talk about it because that's
more offline what's interesting is that
they're sort of like critically stable
these things and as you train them more
they get all closer and closer to being
almost unstable and so these methods
typically are able to find kind of you
know nicer routes then that would take a
very very long number of iterations to
actually converge to if you just did the
unrolling of the forward iteration so
maybe we'll talk about that more offline
it's it's or maybe I wasn't quite
answering your question but hopefully I
was getting at the main point
Yeah right okay okay
another great question specialist yet to
solve the equilibrium accurately the
answer is no you can I mean we did it
first which is why we have that that
slower thing we've sped it up a little
bit by requiring like 10 to negative 1
so so zero point 1 residual was required
we stopped then this is a very common
thing in indirect methods right you just
stop when you're close enough and I
don't have it here but in the paper what
we have a plot of and again it's not
quite out yet but it'll be out in a few
days we have a plot of the solution you
converge to versus stopping criteria and
it's basically flat at the same level
until you get to like zero zero point
one and then of course it shoots up
because if you have you know if you're
not converging at all then then you're
not learning anything so so but you can
go very very loose with that convergence
criteria and practice yeah if you what
do you mean by that of the network
itself I think it's another thought
candle issue I mean you can you can
prune the network for most reasonable
prunings that will still be stable
you're just making weights weights more
toward zero that's isn't gonna probably
make them unstable but but I think
printing before hands kind of strange so
maybe like you're printing it afterwards
them at that I mean I think I think
you've a very fine I think I think there
there there are thuggin or things like
that specifically all right let me get
to the the final bit but I guess you
already all trust the results are gonna
be good so so maybe I'll say it I'll say
those for a second but yeah one more
question correct yes and those are
themselves sort of good representatives
both in practice and in theory for any
finite depth you can play that trick of
just encoding it along these sort of
like these like but the clip with this
like shift operator so for any finite
depth you can you can to get the same
thing with a with an infinitely depth
deep model also
okay so now the part that I guess
everyone's I've said this already seven
was gonna be
convinced already by this but we're
gonna play this put it to the task of
sequence modeling so CBO's modeling
basically is the problem of given a
sequence of inputs x1 to XT predict some
set of outputs of the same size in our
case here y1 through YT where the
constraint is that this has to be causal
prediction so your prediction at time T
can only depend on X up to that point
and that causal structure is basically
embedded in the structure and they
allowed relationships of these hidden
layers and many common there are many
lots of common occupation for this
there's of course recurrent networks
convolutional networks recently
transformers have sort of taken the the
mantle as the as the go-to model for a
lot of sequence modelling tasks and of
course there lots of applications you
know time series prediction language
modeling lots of things what we're gonna
do in picked up these results we're
gonna build two versions of these decks
deep equilibrium if ever you say ekiden
before but we're gonna be used to decks
4 4 sequence modeling and the reality is
you can easily extend the methods that
we just described previously sort of
just just you know roll by private sort
of play sort of rote application to what
kind of whatever kind of module you want
so we create two modules here we have a
deck trellis net Charles net was our
previous work on kind of unifying the
ideas of our n ends and and temporal
compositional networks together and we
have a version of on a transformer so
transformers are of course this settle
attention network that has kind of taken
over the world of say language modeling
and also you know for both predictive
models as well as sort of these these
encoding these sort of word embedding
models and we're gonna have versions of
each of these and what I mean by that is
we sort of take the single layer of one
of these networks and by layer here I do
mean maybe a few layers because again
like a Ellis net will have LS TM like
gates transformers will have a self
attention layer followed by a linear
layer followed by a non linear operator
followed by a linear layer followed by a
layer normal things like this and so we
just embed that as the as the unit layer
and these deep networks and have
consider an infinitely unrolled version
of that Network now we are not going to
play any of those tricks I said before
about Ashley you know stacking
the weights in a way that makes them
equivalent to a deep network we're gonna
let the weights be arbitrary and we're
gonna make them a little bit bigger such
that a total parameter count is equal to
the parameter count of the original
model that's how we're gonna sort of
match match models here so the first
thing I'll mention is just a few small
scale benchmarks and this isn't sort of
uninteresting I suppose but on sort of
standard tasks like copy memory tasks
because it sort of a standard tool for
evaluating was for a long time at least
for evaluating our current networks they
work fine a little bit better but this
difference here is meaningless it's
basically just this task is you have
sort of a sequence you have a lot of
zeros get to then previously was at the
end again and it works fine for that on
things like you know small scale
language modeling like penn treebank
here we're comparing just a trellis that
transformers this is too small
unfortunately it's like the eminence of
language modeling at this point so so
transformers actually are too powerful I
think for this for the cell but
essentially it so I'm trying here is a
travel to that structure on it which
gets you know not state-of-the-art but
certainly competitive results without a
lot of tax for this and we basically
recover the same performance as the
trellis net 60 layer trial sent on this
the difference being that this this one
you know get the same perplexity
performance but you know uses about
eight times as much memory because in a
secluded trails now you have to store
all those 60 layers and the hidden
activations as you go whereas for a deck
you have to just store your your one
layer now there are a little bit it
isn't quite there's a constant on this
because you have to also run like your
broad method and sup like this but it's
essentially o of one it's not going to
grow with more depth in fact this is
infinite depth already so you're good
yeah question the gradient checkpoint is
I like that yeah so yeah so we compared
to all those it works better obviously
so the difference with gradient
checkpoint is great a point is route
depth right I mean you have other
schemes you get other schemes to do it
differently but then you have more
compute if it's log tap like a lot more
compute us log depth right should be
aspect of log of log n right yeah so so
usually yes so we compared to the
gradient checkpointing it works better
than this it smart it's more marginal
than memory like a big computation it's
sort of you know it's on a pre talker
with the other ones a little bit better
some cases a little bit worse in other
cases but again like did you know
fundamentally here it's still a No
one technique right and and so I think
that's the that's the idea here is a
little bit more fundamental than that I
think as a practical technique it's it's
on the border right now but we have to
see is it going to really compete you
know against grating checkpointing in
terms of all these things but right now
it is it is better to declare when we
test it against it's just there are
other parameters can probably to higher
slower so sorry so inference speed is is
the baseline is tell us that and we're
about 1.9 times that because it's a run
born iterations for longer because we're
actually converging to a fixed points a
puts it on okay let me show the final
one now this is actually the last that I
have because we're out of time but I'm
going to talk about now wikitext 103
which is a reasonable size data set not
the biggest one it's a reasonable size
text Mulund data set and we're gonna
compare against mainly transformer Excel
models which are a state of the art
language modeling technique that they're
really good for sort of light predictive
language models which is a transformer
technique that stores some history in
its update equations okay so someone
just go through these and you see you'll
see a common pattern here so on small
with a five million parameters you know
they get similar performance the deck
transformer versus the transformer Excel
again with less memory for the deck for
trellis nets with 70 layer one again
similar performance here a little bit
better here but similar performance and
much less memory consumption transformer
medium similar stories actually do a
little bit worse here which I'm sad
about but I think that's morally we just
explored is that for GPU thing it takes
a long time to run and yeah we don't
have the resources that some certain in
certain places but they must have but
again the story is similar in the
transformer excels gets you know 24
perplexity on this data set but using
quite a bit more memory than this and
this sort of you know the these results
hold kind of at a wider range wide
intermediate range now I just want to
highlight we are not state of the art
yet so if you train transformers with
225 million parameters on T on several
TP use like a TPU pod for a long time
you get better performance and we can't
match that yet I think we still have a
ways to go
both answer boats maybe conceptually in
terms of making this work but also just
resource wise we don't have that but for
the biggest models we can actually run
on
gpus which are these two models here we
do in fact match the performance of
state-of-the-art models while
essentially having much less memory
consumption and also less than degrading
checkpointing in this case when we put
with your green check pointing actually
these aren't lead deep enough to make a
big difference there's only like 12
layers deep imagining performance with
one layer being all you need okay
last last last question again about talk
on emerging challenges and stuff so the
big question to me is how should we
think about depth in deep networks we've
always thought about there were not
always but I think a lot of us think
about death is kind of this hierarchy
this fixed level of profit is fixed
layers of processing to go from one
representation to another and I think
that's true to a certain extent there's
there's no question that this is true
but I think there needs to be more
consideration in this viewpoint of these
networks as dynamical systems and what
we're doing when we run these things
feed for you know in a feed-forward
fashion is we're compute I mean even if
maybe we don't have weight tying is
we're getting towards some notion of an
equilibrium point of some nonlinear
dynamics I think that perspective on
what deep networks are doing itself is
quite valuable I think it will have a
lot of applications of course you know a
big question is what other domains we'll
just work on we haven't done much yet
but I think it opens a lot of doors and
questions about how we think about
networks and hopefully will lead to the
next you know set of things that beat
the transformer maybe in their next
iteration thanks very much I know we're
out of time so may we'll just take
questions offline and people can start
if somebody's like
we went dying to take the last question
keep everyone else from with lunch more
than I have
[Applause]